Alaskan bush people is about a large
family struggling to live off the land
in you guessed it Alaska but the brown
family may not be struggling as much as
you might think here's the real truth
about the show and the family behind it
born rich Billy Brian Brown admits in
his own writing that he wasn't born in
Alaska he claims to have been born in a
world of privilege to a Texas limo
company president in his words I was
given new boats and cars for my
birthday's I was truly the luckiest kid
in town
I had it all money clothes big-ticket
toys and a loving family too sadly
Brown's parents perished in a plane
crash in 1969 after which Brown says he
did odd jobs around Texas and New Mexico
to make ends meet teen bride radar
Online reports that ami Brown was only
15 years old when she married William
Bryan Brown in 1979 Billy was 26
accounting for an 11-year age gap that's
illegal in most states today and creepy
everywhere always probably richer than
they look while the family's exact net
worth is difficult to determine without
examining their tax returns it's safe to
assume they're not as poor as they want
us to believe why well for one thing
they get paid to be on television a deal
that's usually at least kind of
lucrative for the participants no matter
what bushes they like to live in Billy
Brian Brown accomplished writer the
family patriarch has over 70 books under
his belt one of which one wave at a time
actually inspired the television show
that's impressive for someone who
ostensibly has never used anything
beyond candlelight in a fountain pen to
write let alone a typewriter computer or
the Internet speaking of the kids use
technology in 2008 Gabriel Brown wearing
a tank top
posted a YouTube video about his life he
talks about his father's book tour and a
potential movie deal stemming from one
wave at a time he says it's the first
time any of the kids have been out of
the wilderness quote the first time
we've ever seen a traffic jam or eaten
fast food he says that they'll post
videos for the duration of the tour
which is an odd activity if they're not
skilled in technology he ends the video
with impersonations of celebrities the
same celebrities that he'd never have
known about if he didn't have access to
television or the Internet huh the
Browns may have to leave the bush
ami Brown suffers from cervical
radiculitis a form of arthritis in her
neck she told radar online quote it's
just something I think I'm going to have
to live with it limits me on things that
I can do that I like to do and enjoy to
do definitely makes it hard to live
there it's sad and true meanwhile Billy
Brian Brown struggles with seizures have
been documented on the show if they
continue he'll have to stop pretending
to live like a barbarian for a while and
spend more time closer to hospitals they
know how to party Matt Brown was
arrested in 2013 for DUI after what
radar online describes as a night of
some pretty hard partying he was pulled
over for driving drunk and hitting a
parked car in a Walmart parking lot at
4:45 in the morning after which he very
animatedly told his arresting officer
about hooking up with a girl named Julie
in a nearby bar he was sentenced to
three days in jail and 18 months of
probation no word on whether or not
Julie ever called him back though they
might be fraudsters Billy Brian Brown
was charged with 24 counts of unsworn
falsification and theft in January 2016
while radar Online reports that Aimee
and son Solomon and Gabe were each
charged with eight counts sons Noah and
Josh also face six counts each ABC
reports that Brown allegedly live an
official government application
regarding their Alaskan residency in
order to receive Permanent Fund dividend
checks from the state Billy and son Josh
pleaded guilty and were each sentenced
to 30 days in jail the family was
ordered to pay 21 thousand dollars in
restitution to the state of Alaska in an
official statement on the case
Billy Brown said quote Alaska's dividend
program a specific requirement the
length of time in the state and the
reasons for being out of Alaska because
the way we live our lives in the way we
often unconventionally travel I didn't
keep good track of our movements I
accept full responsibility for filing
for benefits without confirming that
we've met the requirements we are
committed to living in Alaska for the
long term and we respect the state's
rules I thought it best has settled to
put this behind us thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more videos like the one you just saw
you